bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition d' europe hebdo votre
rendez vous de l'actualité européenne
des chaînes parlementaires dans cette
édition direction l'irlande un pays qui
après quatre ans d'austérité a annoncé
il ya quelques semaines sortir du plan
daide mis en place par les instances
internationales
mais le tigre celtique est il sorti de
la crise pas si sûr mais d'abord
l'actualité l'europe est sous le choc
après le référendum suisse qui rejette
l'immigration de masse alors à cent
jours des élections européennes
est ce une répétition générale c'est la
question la semaine
un dimanche soir d'hiver l'europe s'est
réveillée groggy
victoire par ko 1 nul percute venu tout
droit de suisse à une courte majorité de
50,3 % les habitants ont approuvé la
limitation de l'immigration sur leur
territoire par une votation populaire
cette petite habitude qui a si souvent
secoué l'europe
en 2009 déjà les minarets des mosquées
furent interdits du coup l'union
européenne à trois ans pour revoir les
accords de libre circulation avec la
suisse bien marchandises capital
personnes une petite sortie du marché
unique pour un pays qui n'en fait pas
vraiment partie
dans les capitales des 28 ce café valeur
d'exemple et les cris d'orfraie n'ont
pas tardé à jaillir car ce référendum
contre l'immigration de masse a été
saluée par tous les partis d'extrême
droite ou de droite populiste européen
alors ce référendum une grande
répétition avant les européennes
et pour répondre à cette question
sensible c'est constance le grip que je
reçois bonjour bonjour vous êtes députée
européenne membre du groupe du parti
populaire européen vous êtes l'ancienne
conseillère europe de nicolas sarkozy
alors quand vous voyez un petit peu ce
qui s'est passé en suisse sur cette
votation est la manière dont ça explose
et un petit peu au visage des dirigeants
européens
est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre à une
répétition générale à cent jours des
élections européennes alors je ne pense
pas que la consultation suisse soit une
répétition générale ou une préfiguration
de la consultation électorale européenne
de fin mai
2014 néanmoins c'est vrai que c'est un
message politique fort et un coup de
semonce qui nous est adressé par le
peuple helvétique je ne me cacherai pas
derrière des paravents de juridisme
pointilleux de légalisme exacerbée et je
n'aurais pas ni l'arrogance mais la
condescendance de vous la renvoyez le
peuple helvétique ses chères études vous
dire mes chers amis vous n'avez pas
compris vous vous êtes j'ai entendu les
formules qui m'ont semblé un peu
méprisante tirer une balle dans le pied
vous avez scier la branche laquelle vous
à passer en démocratie quand le peuple
parle le peuple doit être entendue dans
son jour si jamais marine le pen comme
ça à l'air bien parti selon les derniers
sondages et le premier parti de france
vous serez capable d'entendre le fait
que le peuple à voter contre l'ump qui a
été au pouvoir le ps et cette europe que
jean françois copé dit on les aime
tellement qu'on veut la changer
incontestablement il y a une forte
interrogation dans les opinions
publiques européennes sur le chemin que
parcourt en ce moment l'union européenne
quelle robe voulons nous avec qui
voulons nous continuer à cheminer
ensemble et pourquoi faire ces
interrogations là qui se traduisent en
angoisse en doute quasi existentielle
nous devons les entendre nous devons les
considérer et nous devons surtout nous
partis de gouvernement partis ayant
vocation à revenir au gouvernement en
france l'ump y apporter des réponses les
entendre avec je dirais considération et
y apporter tenter d'y apporter des
réponses crédibles ou sérieuse
responsable quelle réponse constance il
faut se remettre de la politique au
coeur du processus décisionnel européen
il faut que les politiques qu'ils soient
élus européens élus nationaux
gouvernants gouvernants de l'europe
gouvernants des états membres remettent
clairement de la politique au coeur des
processus décisionnels n'esquive pas les
débats aient compris les débats de fond
qui peuvent poser problème y compris les
débats une opération qu'on repousse
quand même aux calendes grecques depuis
quelques mois calendes grecques je ne
sais pas moi je joue cette musique
souffre de lésions au fait les gars
faits par la grèce je ne sais pas très
bien ce que veut dire les calendes
grecques alors on repousse oui non il ya
quand même une notamment pendant la
présidence française de l'union
européenne au deuxième semestre de
l'année 2008 un pacte européen pour
l'asile et l'immigration qui avait été
négociée par brice hortefeux portée par
nicolas sarkozy et qui avait été adoptée
à l'unanimité par l'ensemble des membres
du conseil européen saluer également
accueillie avec beaucoup d'enthousiasmé
et de volonté politique au parlement
européen mais qui tout en définissant
des objectifs très clairs et du pilier
commun pour une véritable politique
commune européenne
l'immigration l'émigration clandestine
qui doit être combattu avec
détermination l'immigration légale qui
doit être maîtrisée qui doit être
choisie a pas subi et bien un centre de
ses préconisations et l'affirmation de
cette volonté politique sont ensuite
restées lettre morte effectivement donc
on a eu un certain nombre de pas en
avant et puis ensuite on a un peu oublié
sous la pression quotidienne et bien
évidemment compréhensible de la crise
financière de la crise dans la zone euro
et sert a mis au second plan des
préoccupations je dirais régaliennes qui
à mon sens doivent être dans le débat
européen et doivent être pris en main
par les dirigeants européens je voudrais
revenir sur les ressortissants français
qui travaillent notamment en suisse les
transfrontaliers ils sont entre 100 et
150 mille selon les sources qu'est ce
qui va se passer pour eux aujourd'hui on
s'interroge sur le sort de ces
travailleurs frontaliers moi je serai
pas actuellement attentive je pense le
web en français également au sort qui
sera fait aux travailleurs frontaliers à
commencer par les travailleurs
frontaliers français ceux-ci ne doivent
pas rester dans une incertitude et une
insécurité juridique qui alors il reçoit
la lettre en question donc les les
acquis si je puis dire de la suisse qui
ne fait pas partie de l'union européenne
mais qui bénéficiait de la libre
circulation
c'est à dire un des capitaux des
services dans l'espace schengen
exactement clairement là en gros on a
quand même entendu
et des phrases un petit peu dur
vis-à-vis de la suisse qui disait donc
c'est cette fameuse guillotine qui
fleurira loti losio team qui remet en
question à partir du moment où on remet
en question une partie en fait des
acquis ça remet tout en question est ce
que ça veut dire que l'europe va faire
un exemple avec la suisse sachant que à
partir de 2017 l'angleterre est un petit
peu sur la même visée de faire un
référendum sur la participation ou non à
l'espace
dans l'union européenne je ne pense pas
qu'il va faire de la suisse en
l'occurrence ni un modèle ni un exemple
n'est même faire du cas suisse un
exemple qui serait à méditer les paroles
par les autres encore une fois il faut
raison garder il faut prendre son temps
se garder de postures intempestives et
de déclarations et de jugements à
l'emporte-pièce incontestablement on est
devant un casse tête juridique il ya
évidemment cette fameuse clause
guillotine mais les choses ne sont pas
aussi simple que cela et tout le château
de cartes n'est pas en train de
s'effondrer sous nos yeux d'un seul coup
d'un seul on efface et c'est pour ça que
effectivement la surprise a été grande
parce qu'on n'avait pas anticipé ça je
dirais dans les capitales européennes ni
à bruxelles sa santé peut on n'avait pas
le
mécanismes juridiques alternatif près
dans les tiroirs on est face à un
casse-tête juridique un casse-tête
institutionnels il faut de prendre du
temps pour voir comment effectivement
éviter une situation qui pour le coup
serait à mon sens préjudiciable pour la
suite du projet européen qui est ce que
les britanniques appellent cherry
picking ce à dire que tel ou tel pays
viendraient picorer des cerises
prendrait ce qui la range retrait
l'arrangera et serra et se mettrait à
pratiquer une espèce de politiquement à
la carte on prend voilà on ne prend pas
le menu mais on prend la cafétéria
l'europe à la carte là effectivement
pour le coup ça mérite maintenant du
temps et de l'approfondissement dans la
réflexion parce qu'il faut qu'on puisse
aborder la question suisse à l'aune de
cette vision globale l'europe c'est pas
ben là car c'est tout à la grèce écoutez
consensus merci d'avoir évoqué le cas
suisse avec nous nous on continue dans
la partie magazine de cette émission il
y a quelques semaines l'irlande
annonçait sortir du plan daide organisée
par les instances internationales
après quatre ans de crise alors pour
autant est-ce que le tigre celtique
recommence à rugir pas si sûr c'est
faustine saint-geniès qui s'est rendue à
dublin
bienvenue en silicone dox dans le
quartier du canal à dublin les immeubles
flambant neufs ont remplacé les vieux
entrepôts aucun logo apparent mais
derrière ces murs amazon facebook
youtube paypal tous les géants du web
ont leur pied-à-terre ici à commencer
par google qui ne cesse de s'agrandir
j'étais à côté aussi appartient à google
suit qu'il est derrière nous et puis je
suis tombé moi aussi là haut qui avaient
continué à embaucher tous les jours
pendant encore 20 derrière
ça n'arrête pas une aubaine pour
constances mas s'est expatrié à dublin
qui a perdu son travail en février
dernier j'ai mis mon cv à jour sur
internet et j'ai été démarché tout de
suite donc trois semaines à avoir après
avoir appris que j'étais j'étais
licencié
le secret de l'irlande pour attirer les
entreprises son impôt sur les sociétés à
douze ennemis pour cent l'un des plus
bas d'europe et malgré la crise pas
question de toucher à cette fiscalité
très avantageuse
en temps de crise la dernière chose à
faire dans une politique industrielle
c'est de créer de l'incertitude
c'était important pour nous de garder un
impôt sur les sociétés à 12 et demi pour
cent il est resté à ce niveau et ne
changera pas
quatre ans après la crise l'irlande est
le premier pays à être sorti du plan de
sauvetage de l'union européenne et du
fmi mais au prix d'une cure d'austérité
drastique le discours officiel se veut
optimiste
pourtant les stigmates de la crise sont
encore bien visibles après l'explosion
de la bulle immobilière
comme ce centre commercial fantôme sur
les docks
et dans la banlieue de dublin on ne
compte plus les rues abandonnées comme
ici à priori rôle
diogo a subi de plein fouet la récession
il y a 6 ans elle était chef
d'entreprise et sa maison valait 1
million et demi d'euros elle a perdu 90%
de sa valeur
les styles comment va-t-il bien ces
temps-ci assieds-toi les pères après un
divorce et la faillite de son entreprise
elle a connu une descente aux enfers
j'ai pensé au suicide pendant les six
mois où j'étais au plus mal je ne peux
pas dire que je ne vais pas envisager
j'ai su ce que c'était que d'être au
bord du gouffre j'ai su ce que c'était
que de ne plus avoir aucun espoir
heureusement j'ai deux enfants ce qui
m'a empêché de passer à l'acte
la banque a fini par saisir sa maison
jill se retrouve avec une dette de plus
d'un million d'euros pour l'aider dans
ses démarches
davy drôle il a fondé un organisme qui
aide les irlandais surendettés
aujourd'hui il y a deux irlande une qui
s'en sort et une qui n'arrivent pas à
joindre les deux bouts les statistiques
le prouvent le seul chiffre qui n'a
cessé d'augmenter depuis le début de la
crise c'est bien l'endettement des
ménages
désormais jean n'a qu'un rêve repartir à
zéro
j'espère que lundi prochain j'aurai
suffisamment de retard de paiement pour
être déclaré en faillite personnelle
ouais la banque où nous
nous retrouvons constance qui vite à
dublin depuis trois ans et demi
traductrice de formation à 26 ans elle
gagne environ 2000 euros net par mois
avec frédéric une amie expatriés elle
aussi elle voit dans l'irlande un
eldorado
réservé aux étrangers
ici les entreprises américaines father
leur siège européen et dans chacun
entreprises américaines on va avoir une
équipe française une équipe espagnole
une équipe portugaise allemande et donc
si on parle une langue européenne
on a plus de chance de trouver de
trouver un bon travail ici j'ai des amis
qui sont irlandais
qui enchaîne les stages ou les
tentatives de formation pourrait essayer
de s'en sortir parce que à dublin le
travail il n'est pas pour lui et pour
nous le chômage touche en effet 13 % de
la population est plus du double chez
les jeunes même les plus diplômés
quittent le pays
professeur de finance à trinity college
charles foulard qui nous voient ces
étudiants immigrés comme sean connery
bonjour chaîne bonjour comment allez
vous pas mal
donc cours en master i lie à presque 100
% des étudiants irlandais qui partent
titulaires d'un master en finance chez
une connerie enchaîne les petits boulots
les entreprises où je travaillais ont
fait faillite mon patron a perdu son
bien au jeu les chevilles c'est très dur
de se débrouiller ici
ma copine à deux masters et gère un
restaurant survivre en irlande est une
vraie lutte en jeu
que vous voyez c'est un effet d'optique
l'état veut une belle histoire l'europe
veut une belle histoire et ils vont
travailler que ce soit la réelle
je fais
depuis 2008 plus de trois cent mille
personnes ont quitté le territoire pour
l'essentiel des moins de 35 ans
alors l'irlande est elle en train de
raconter une belle histoire à l'europe
pour en parler je reçois de députés sur
ce plateau philippe l'emmerdent bonjour
vous êtes député vert vous êtes membre
de la commission des affaires
économiques et financières et alejandro
cercas vous êtes député socialiste et
démocrate et vous vous êtes au sein de
la commission emploi et affaires
sociales rapporteur de la commission d'
enquête sur la troïka ce que vous êtes
aussi finalement parce qu'on a deux
rapports sur l'action la troïka au sein
de ce parlement un de la commission
affaires économiques et l'autre de la
commission emploi et affaires sociales
alors messieurs quand vous voyez ce
reportage est ce que en gros il ya l'on
n'est pas en train de nous raconter une
belle histoire avec des violons
alejandro cercas oui mais il faudra
godet l'histoire complet parce que nous
craignons beaucoup qu'on va raconter une
partie de l'histoire l'histoire de la
banque l'histoire des marchés n'est pas
l'histoire des jardins normaux et les
premiers de chaque jour deux jeunes des
chômeurs des malades et tout ça alors
c'est pour ça que nous allons faire un
rapport aussi à la commission d'emploi
des affaires sociales pour écouter aussi
les caisses qu'ils disent les âmes et
l'irlande l'élan si vous permettez c'est
même si on aurait dit un
reportage sur la grèce au portugal c'est
encore pire bien sûr et on voit que
c'est la catastrophe sociale et la
catastrophe est structurel ça va durer
beaucoup de temps donc en fait l'irlande
nous raconte des histoires quand on dit
c'est pas juste irlande je veux dire à
la banque centrale européenne à la
commission européenne au conseil
européens à l'eurogroupe on a besoin
d'aller raconter une histoire qui peut
quelque part a posteriori légitime les
politiques d'austérité massifs qui ont
été imposées donc ils ont besoin de ça
on est en année électorale il faut aller
raconter un truc et on s'en fout de
savoir si fondamentalement les faits
étaient l'histoire ou pas l'important
c'est de dire que regarder le premier
pays s'en est sorti soit dit en passant
quel est le critère de succès qu'ils
utilisaient et c'est vraiment
intéressant il faut vraiment lire les
mots lorsque olli rehn le commissaire
européen aux affaires économiques et
monétaires dit regardez l'irlande s'en
sort elle a retrouvé l'accès aux marchés
financiers autrement dit c'est comme ça
qu'on a le critère de succès le critère
de succès c'est l'accès aux marchés
financiers donc en fait au dessus de la
démocratie vous avez les marchés
financiers qui sont les juges finalement
de la qualité des politiques menées et
de ce point de vue là l'irlande peut de
nouveau emprunter de l'argent parce que
c'est ça on fait de la dernière émission
obligataire a plutôt bien marché elle
peut emprunter de l'argent donc rentrer
chez vous dormez en paix bonnes gens
tout va bien on se pose évidemment par
la question comme le disait alejandro de
savoir au fait comment ça se fait qu'ils
payent jeudi on est passé de 23 %
d'irlande et au sommet de la prospérité
23% d'irlande est au seuil de pauvreté
et l'exclusion sociale à 29 %
aujourd'hui
29 % d'une population entière d'une
population qui est au seuil de pauvreté
ou d'exclusion sociale est ce qu'on se
rend compte de ce qui est en train de se
passer enfin l'économie est là pour
servir le bien être des gens mais de ce
point de vue là je n'appelle pas ça un
succès alors moi je comprends que les
marchés financiers trouve ça un succès
évidemment ils ont été pas investir ils
ont été jetés de l'argent dans une bulle
immobilier ils n'ont pas perdu un kopeck
évidemment c'est un succès pour eux
c'est un grand succès mais donc ce qu'on
a fait c'est privatiser verdon c'est
nationaliser delà des privés autrement
dit on a permis à des banques et pas
seulement les banques irlandaises les
banques allemandes et banques françaises
et britanniques les banques belges etc
qui ont alimenté la bulle irlandaise on
leur a permis de se tirer d'affaires
après avoir privatisé les bénéfices on à
socialiser les pertes voilà alors
justement sur vous vous qui travaillez
sur cet aspect en fait emploi affaires
sociales est ce qu on a complètement
oublié les peuples dans cette histoire
on voit jill qui a plus d'un million
d'euros de dette
finalement comme quelle est votre
lecture un petit peu de tout ça mais
écoutez et on a fait des solutions dans
notre commission et écouter l'origine
internationale du travail le conseil de
l'europe il les a demandé est-ce que
vous ça et une demande et quelque chose
on le comité des politiques et sociales
qu'il existait dans l'union européenne
le comité et des emplois existent et
tous les regards des
ddd consultation que nous avons n'ont
été jamais consultés c'est à dire c'est
comme si c'était réalité des gens
normaux n'hésitez pas c'est en lui ses
fils se sont simplement la gestion
macroéconomique et la banque belgique
n'existait pas et ça c'est quand
l'europe parce que l'europe l'article 7
du traité d fonctionnement de l'union
européenne dit que toutes les politiques
doit être miné pour un haut niveau
d'emploi et un haut niveau de protection
sociale mais dans ces cas au nom
totalement totalement ils ont travaillé
ils ont travaillé avec l'idée que si la
banque et sauver tout le monde est sauvé
mais je voudrais ajouter les choses
parce que nous n'avons pas beaucoup tant
il faut le dire les dommage quand on
voit les reportages de l'irlande selon
paco d'une tourelle quand on voit que
25% de la population jeune c'est aussi
dans mon pays et entraînent des valises
des sandales et doctorat d'ingénieur et
tout ça quel est l'avenir des civils
quels sont les dommages qu on a fait pas
semblant que voudrait et structurelle
parce que ils ont détruit beaucoup
cherchent qu'il faudra reconstruire
parce que sinon ce n'est pas seulement
la situation qui ont marqué ses
photographies et ses films c'est que ça
va durer longtemps parce que les forces
qu'il y avait pour l'innovation les
forces pour l'avenir l'espoir la
situation en irlande en référé c'est
catastrophique
il y à toute une génération qui n'a pas
espoir pour l'avenir comment faire des
entreprises comme un oeuf et
entreprendre comment faire c'est
pourtant et quand il regardait
simplement les banques qu'ils ont en
effet un énorme erreur même économique
alors effectivement il ya la question de
l'exode et de l'émigration des irlandais
donc on retrouve en espagne au portugal
en grèce il ya aussi un autre problème
qui a été pointée par nombre de
dirigeants européens c'est le problème
de l'optimisation fiscale bien sûr nos
amis irlandais ont réussi à maintenir
coûte que coûte leur taux d'imposition
des entreprises à 12 et demi pour cent
contre parfois plus de 30 % pour
certains pays européens est-ce qu'on a
affaire ici à un paradis fiscal bien sûr
mais je pense qu'il faut être bon compte
il serait de mauvais aloi de pointer le
doigt exclusivement en direction de
l'irlande en ce qui m'a en ce qui
concerne l'optimisation fiscale je vais
dire bien des montages qui sont faits et
qui l'utilisent l'irlande pour permettre
à des gens comme google amazon et
d'autres de ne pas il ya là des roues
quelques semaines font appel à des
dispositifs législatifs qui se trouve
dans la législation du grand duché du
luxembourg dans la législation
néerlandaise et donc ça c'est un montage
y aura plein d'autres je veux dire les
paradis fiscaux en europe se comptent
par dizaines et donc en effet l'irlande
est un d'entre eux et donc là on peut se
poser la question de la conditionnalité
des aides européennes
on met des conditionnalités sur les
politiques d'austérité on impose
finalement la nationalisation de la
dette privée c'est-à-dire en fait outre
le million que gilles va devoir repayer
espérons qu'elle soit déclarée en
faillite eh bien je rappelle que tous
les contribuables irlandais se retrouve
avec une dette publique qu'ils vont
devoir assumer qui est passé de feintes
et quelques pour cent à 117 % du pib ils
sont partis pour 30 ans et là évidemment
c'est quelque chose qu'on dit moins
facilement et en effet si on veut que
cette dette soit apurer bien on pourrait
dire écoutez les gars vous devez imposer
les entrepreneurs l'argument des
irlandais cette nuit là dessus parce que
il n'est pas insensé l'irlande dit nous
sommes des favorisés par la géographie
et c'est vrai et c'est vrai et c'est
vrai qu'ils iraient ils n'avaient pas
cette dame n'est pas insensé dans un
dispositif fiscal harmonisée au niveau
européen de permettre à des pays
périphériques de compenser leur
désavantage par un avantage fiscal de
manière à remettre les pendules afin de
remettre les compteurs à zéro d'avoir un
terrain de jeu qui soit raisonnablement
équilibrer le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas ça chacun
essaye de tirer son épingle du jeu
l'irlande de son côté la belgique du
sien la france du sien de la grande
bretagne et tous ces petits territoires
du leur et donc aujourd'hui si on veut
vraiment convaincre l'irlande de changer
sa politique de dumping fiscal il faut
alors que tous les états européens
acceptent de mettre fin à leurs propres
paradis fiscaux parce que ce que vous
dit c'est que chez nous c'est 12 et demi
pour cent mais ses douze ennemis % en
france nominalement c'est peut-être 30
mai avec toutes les niches fiscales
louis alexandre sambat église voilà
exactement identique souhaite de bon
compte alors justement je vous
interromps juste à l'instant il y à
notre économiste dans le sujet qui avait
une question directe à vous poser on les
écoute
enfin de la question clé c'est comment
l'europe s'attaque au problème écrasant
de la lèze
des problèmes qu'il existe seulement en
irlande mais aussi dans d'autres pays
comme l'italie l'espagne et la grèce
et il vaut mieux faire bouger l'économie
que de s'accuser mutuellement
c'est ce qui se passe de mon point de
vue dans les discussions sur l'europe et
sur les réformes de l'union européenne
tout cela avance très lentement
alejandro cercas où en est-on justement
de cette question de la gestion de la
crise et de la dette mais la question de
l'allaitement d une fois plus et ils ont
regardé la réalité en dehors des charges
fondamentaux pas comme l'espagne c'est
un champion de la dette publique avant
de la clis nous nous étions au dessus de
la moyenne maintenant les doubles
pourquoi parce que les greniers a fondu
parce qu'il n'y a pas laissé un goût de
me le dire et qu'est ce que l'on dit ici
la banque centrale de toul et tous les
types et ultralibéraux il faut couper
les dépenses mais jamais et parler des
recettes et des centres est alors quand
l'économie est sous les 0 quand on
détruit les entreprises par centaines et
milliers comme en espagne quand on a
aucune demande était bienvenue parce que
les entreprises n'ont pas avec la
clientèle tout le symbole tombe alors
ils étaient infondées de son austérité
dans les dépenses publiques mais il faut
rien pour animer l'économie alors l'abbé
traduit pas simplement au résultat net
aux multiples et la décision si on paye
la bête comme nous l'avons fait nous
serons payés chaque année 38 milliard d
euros pour payer simplement des intérêts
de la dette aux banques et aux prêteurs
internationale si nous on demandé de
payer notre être publié trois fois plus
cher qu'en france ou en allemagne nos
entreprises sont aussi chargés au même
type à des titres et l'intérêt que les
secteurs publics ils sont dans la
concurrence déloyale c'est pour ça que
l'irlandais des seniors très intéressant
il disait il ya des sortes et d'irlande
mais je crois qu'il ya aussi des classes
des repères maintenant les pays ton pays
une voiture et non les pays les peuples
oui il y en d'autres au contraire comme
augmenter le produit augmenter l'emploi
augmenter la richesse ont pris les
marchés à la halle du parc d'olhain
entre autres bien sûr alors la crise a
été gérée pas pour résoudre le problème
de la dette pour se dépanner et logique
contre les le secteur public pour couper
les beaux coupés le dialogue social pour
faire des choses épouvantables
alors je vais jouer un petit peu la
provocation l'islande par exemple a
décidé d'annuler purement et simplement
la dette est ce qu'on peut imaginer la
même chose pour l'espagne pour le
portugal pour la grèce bon je crois
qu'une petit pays on ne peut pas faire
un espagnol est bien question qu'on
avait un petit pays si je pagny c'est ce
que ça c'était la faillite et tous les
cas c'est la science il ya quelques
années non non non c'est la faillite et
la france donne au moment où on a erré
la grèce connaît entre guillemets parce
que pas un seul euro allemand ou francis
maintenant dans l'adresse cela ils ont
fait des nouvelles est prête ou le fait
de sa souffrance mais si on tombait la
banque espagnole parce qu'il est en
espagne il est nommé problème des bi
l'immobilier parce que les banques
allemandes les banques françaises que
belges britanniques
s'endetter sans doute et ça dérange les
autres il est tout à fait que robert
alors tout était lié à l'or sa
progression est et comment rembourser
les dettes les mêmes qu'à vérifier à 100
qu'ils la dette privée passer au public
mais c'était pour assurer assuré aussi
la banque des pays central de l'europe
bien sûr est que ce qui passerait
qu'est-ce qu'il aurait eu si l'espagne
fassent la même question de la sacef la
faillite de la banque en français
seulement alors exactement exactement je
pense que la question qui est posée la
question centrale depuis trente ans la
croissance européenne est motorisé par
la dette et on est arrivé à un point où
dans certains compartiments notre
économie dans certains pays cela des
publics dans d'autres pays seraient à
des privés qui a atteint des niveaux ils
remboursent
ça dépend des pays mais c'est en tout
cas il y à une partie de la dette qui
désirent s'en vient pour un plein il
rendit de toute manière structurelle
mais c'est à dire qu' il n'y a pas de
scénario macroéconomique plausible qui
laisse penser qu'il sera possible de
rembourser alors qu'elle est
l'économie financière c'est la coupable
ddt
joliment que l'économie financière
travail pour l'économie réelle et pour
les sociétés et par le contraire
maintenant les rênes sont dans les
maigres économies financières et sont
eux qui commandent et c'est vrai qu'ils
sont systémiques et que s'il tombait
tout tomber tout le monde il est
aujourd'hui en tout cas je dirai tout ça
il s'agirait il n'y a pas moyen que
l'écho que la finance resservent
l'économie si on ne purge pas la partie
irremboursable de la dette et là vous
n'avez pas dix mille manières de le
faire c'est soit de l'inflation mais
tout le monde sait que l'inflation est
socialement très triste c'est soit la
croissance mais se dire qu'on va
retrouver des noirs sens de 4 5 6 %
c'est une illusion c'est soit tu es bien
la restructuration de la dette c'est à
dire retrouver des arrangements en
prolongeant les périodes de
remboursement réduisant les taux
d'intérêt soit un impôt sur la fortune
tels que thomas piketty y propose 1 et
donc ses finances
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi les bruits
financières sont pas taxés au même
niveau que l'été oui alors ça c'est la
taxe sur les transactions financières
messieurs je suis désolé c'est toujours
trop quoi oui ce sera l'objet d'un autre
débat la taxe sur les transactions
financières nous c'est terminé pour
cette semaine rendez vous la semaine
prochaine avec ahmed tazir bonne suite
de programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires